HIS MOBILE PHONE RAISING
QUESTIONS ABOUT ISRAEL'S
NATIONAL SECURITY.
REACTING TO THIS, THE AUTHOR OF,
WOW, 15, 16 WEEKS NOW, NUMBER
ONE ON "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
BEST SELLER, I CALL HIM THE
GREAT ONE, I'M LOOKING AT WHAT
IS HAPPENING IN ISRAEL, AND THEY
HAVE A WORSE FAKE NEWS PROBLEM
THAT WE HAVE COME AWAY WORSE
WORSE, AND I'M THINKING, THIS WU
WORSE, AND I'M THINKING, THIS WD
WORSE, AND I'M THINKING, THIS WB
WORSE, AND I'M THINKING, THIS WE
WORSE, AND I'M THINKING, THIS WM
WORSE, AND I'M THINKING, THIS WR
WORSE, AND I'M THINKING, THIS WE
THAN A ONE-DAY STORY AND DON'T
ASK ME ANY MORE QUESTIONS.
>> I'VE BEEN WATCHING WHAT IS
GOING ON IN ISRAEL AND IT'S VERY
UPSETTING.
IN A WORD, THEIR MEDIA SUCKS.
IT'S VERY LEFT WING.
MUCH LIKE OUR MEDIA HATE THE
DONALD TRUMP.
THE THING ABOUT GANTZ THAT
AMAZES ME, THIS IS A FORMER
GENERAL PURITY THINK HE WOULD
KNOW THAT WHEN HE USES A PRIVATE
PHONE THAT THE IRANIANS OR
SOMEBODY ARE TAPPING IN.
THE IRANIANS KNOW WHAT IS ON THE
PHONE.
THE IRANIANS KNOW WHAT HE SAID
BUT THE ISRAELI PEOPLE DON'T
BECAUSE HE WON'T COME CLEAN.
IN THE UNITED STATES IF YOU
DON'T COME CLEAN ABOUT SOMETHING
LIKE THAT WHETHER IT IS AN
AFFAIR OR WHATEVER ELSE IT IS
YOU CAN'T GET A SECURITY
CLEARANCE.
EVEN THE LOWEST OFFICIAL CAN'T,
WHY?
BECAUSE OF THE POTENTIAL FOR
BLACKMAIL.
IT'S NOT ENOUGH FOR A FORMER
OFFICIAL TO SAY THEY CAN'T
BLACKMAIL ME, NOTHING HAPPENED.
ANOTHER THING, YOU SEE THIS
TODAY AND POLITICAL.
POLITICO IS A LEFT-WING NEW SITE
THAT OBAMA OFFICIALS LOVED TO
LEAK TOO.
ISRAEL ACCUSED OF PLANTING
MYSTERIOUS SPY DEVICES NEAR THE
WHITE HOUSE.
THE TARGET, THEY SAY, IS
INTENDED TO SPY ON DONALD TRUMP.
I THINK I'M ISRAEL, WHY WOULD
THEY DO THAT?
THEN HE READ IN THE ARTICLE,
WHERE DOES THIS COME FROM?
THREE FORMER SENIOR U.S.
OFFICIALS.
IN OTHER WORDS, OBAMA APPOINTEE
APPOINTEES.
OBAMA APPOINTEES PLANTED THIS.
THEY PLANTED IT IN AN AMERICAN
NEWS SITE IN ORDER TO TRY TO
CREATE HOSTILITY BETWEEN OUR
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
PRIME MINISTER WHO ARE VERY
CLOSE.
IN FACT, TRUMP AND NETANYAHU ARE
AS CLOSE AS ANY PRESIDENT HAS
EVER BEEN.
THE WORST PRESIDENT THAT ISRAEL
HAS EVER EXPERIENCED IN ITS
SHORT LIFE AND BY THE WAY, THE
UNITED STATES TOO.
I LOOK AT THIS AND I THINK ABOUT
WHAT IS GOING ON HERE.
FOLLOW THIS.
CLOSER TO WHO?
JOE BENENSON.
WHO IS JOEL BENENSON, AMERICA
AND ISRAEL?
HE WAS A STRATEGIST FOR OBAMA IN
2008 AND 2012.
IN HIS CAMPAIGN.
THE STRATEGIST FOR
HILLARY CLINTON AND HER
CAMPAIGN.
WHO IS HE A STRATEGIST FOR NOW?
THE BLUE AND WHITE PARTY.
THIS IS A DIRTY TRICK.
AT THIS A SLEAZY TRICK.
AMERICANS AND ISRAELIS NEED TO
KNOW THE LEFT-WING IN OUR
COUNTRY AND THE MEDIA IN OUR
COUNTRY ARE LIKE THIS.
THEY WORKED TOGETHER.
JUST AS THEY DO IN ISRAEL.
THEY ARE TRYING TO TAKE ON
NETANYAHU JUST AS THEY ARE
TRYING TO TAKE ON TRUMP TODAY
PAID BY THE WAY NOW THAT YOU
HAVE ME HERE, DO YOU SEE THIS
CUSTOMER AND YOU KNOW WHAT THIS
IS QUEST MONKEYS AT THE
RIDICULOUS ALLEGATIONS
BROUGHT BY RIDICULOUS
ALLEGATIONS AGAINST NETANYAHU.
I DOUBT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE CARE
AND I DOUBT THE ISRAELIS HAVE
ACTUALLY READ THIS.
I READ IT.
AS OF FORMER CHIEF OF STAFF IN
THE REAGAN ADMINISTRATION, THIS
IS IN DISGRACE.
AN ABSOLUTE DISGRACE LIKE THE
ALLEGATIONS AGAINST OUR
PRESIDENT.
I LOOKED AT THE THREE
ALLEGATIONS.
THE FIRST ALLEGATION, THE
PRIME MINISTER OF ISRAEL
ACCEPTED CIGARS AND CHAMPAGNE.
GIFTS.
YOU KNOW WHAT THIS
ATTORNEY GENERAL DID?
HE ADDED GIFTS FROM ANOTHER
PRISON TO MAKE IT LOOK LIKE THE
CIGARS AND CHAMPAGNE THAT
BENJAMIN NETANYAHU RECEIVED WAS
AN ENORMOUS AMOUNT.
YOU KNOW WHAT,
MR. ATTORNEY GENERAL?
WHAT YOU DID IS UNETHICAL.
LOOK AT THE SECOND CHART.
BRIBERY, FRAUD, BREACH OF TRUST.
ON FAIRLY IRRATIONAL.
THE PRIME MINISTER ACTUALLY
REFUSED TO BE BRIBED.
ONE MEDIA OUTLET SEEKS
LEGISLATION THAT WOULD HELP
AGAINST OF THE MEDIA COMPETITOR
IN EXCHANGE FOR POSITIVE NEWS.
THE PRIME MINISTER HAD NO
INTENTION OF PROMOTING THE
LEGISLATION AND IT WASN'T EVEN
POSSIBLE FOR HIM TO PROMOTE THE
LEGISLATION BECAUSE THE
SUSPENSION WAS TAKING PLACE
BEFORE IT COULD EVEN HAPPEN.
THEN I LOOK AT THE THIRD, WHICH
IS SUPPOSED TO BE THE BIG
BLOCKBUSTER CHARGE.
IT'S LOADED WITH HYPERBOLE,
IDIOTIC ASSERTIONS, IT'S ABOUT
PRESS ETHICS.
NOT THE CONDUCT OF THE
PRIME MINISTER OF THE STATE OF
ISRAEL.
CLAIMS THE PRIME MINISTER SOUGHT
POSITIVE MEDIA, LIKE NO
POLITICIAN DOES THAT.
THEY MIGHT AS WELL TAKE A CRIME
TAPE AND WRAP IT AROUND BECAUSE
THIS WEBSITE WAS GOING TO DO
POSITIVE NEWS ON BEHALF OF THE
PRIME MINISTER OF ISRAEL IN
EXCHANGE FOR CERTAIN POLICIES
AND REGULATORY CHANGES.
THERE IS NO DIRECT EVIDENCE
WHATSOEVER IN THIS LONG WINDED,
VERBOSE, FULL OF PHONY
ADJECTIVES CHARGE.
WHAT HE IS BASICALLY SAYING IS I
DON'T LIKE THE PRESS POLICY OF
THIS PARTICULAR PRESS OWNER
AND I DON'T LIKE THE POLICIES OF
THE PRIME MINISTER OF ISRAEL.
THEREFORE, I'M GOING TO MAKE AN
ALLEGATION.
THESE ALLEGATIONS, LIKE THE
CHARGES AGAINST OUR PRESIDENT,
HANG UP THE HEAD OF THE
PRIME MINISTER THROUGHOUT THE
LAST SEVERAL MONTHS.
I WOULD JUST SAY TO THE ISRAELI
ISRAELIS, YOU HAVE THE
MODERN-DAY WINSTON CHURCHILL.
DON'T MAKE THE SAME MISTAKE THE
BRITISH MADE, BECAUSE I
GUARANTEE YOU, THE ENEMIES THAT
SURROUND YOU, PARTICULARLY I
RAN, YOU WILL COME TO REGRET IT.
THAT IS MY PERSONAL OPINION.
>> Sean: I HAPPEN TO SHARE IT.
MORAL CLARITY.
LOOK AT THIS RELATIONSHIP WITH
TRUMP.
RECOGNIZED THE SOVEREIGNTY, LOOK
AT THE PARTNERSHIP THEY HAVE.
I HOPE AND PRAY THE PEOPLE OF